fruits fruits fruits fruits natural
sugar
is what this video is about
wow i've dropped it you can eat the rind
of a guava i don't know if i want to eat
the rind what do i do you can bust up
some teeth with these seeds ah i like
cracker tooth there oh my god that is
really good guava me some more fruits
tamarind
the exoskeleton is very weak it looks
like chocolate
but it smells like these vitamins i used
to give my pet lizard this looks really
weird like it's veiny but it's like a
really nice sweet sack it has like a
date biggie taste am i doing this right
lychee cracking open a can of eyeballs
kind of reminds me of those fruit snacks
my mom used to pack these taste so much
better than they look you could
definitely sip up the juices in this can
oh that's good i like that a lot oh my
gosh that's incredible it's like a
pineapple but better lychee desserts
like a lychee pie has anyone done that
will somebody do that
should i do that dragon fruit this is
not fruit this is art this is the fruit
that everyone should instagram
themselves eating this is giving me like
kiwi vibes it takes me to the ocean
please don't judge me it's kind of like
all show no flavor it's good i just feel
like i'm eating air by looks though this
this takes the cake i need to decorate
my place so if you have some more of
these i'll just put them in various
places in my house
jackfruit uh named after
jack what's up with all these cans oh oh
it's kind of aggressive it's a little uh
rubbery let's see how it's juices tastes
wise it's really good no i like the
lychee better now steve fruit would
probably be pretty good dude what is
that it's like a fruit mush wrapped in a
condom this is a fruit this is just
making me sad looking at this it smells
like rotten cantaloupe smells like
garlic i don't like that can i have a
lychee please
oh actually it's growing on me oh it's
got a great aftertaste this is like
really good i'm pleasantly surprised you
know what
good things come in nasty packages
okay
oh yes